might have been no red box there might
have been no photo call outside downing
street but this was really a budget in
orbit name when you look at the scale of
what we're talking about and we'll start
with the kind of big picture over the
next three years you're talking about 36
billion pounds coming in from new taxes
from that new levy uh but also from tax
on dividends how does that split up and
where is that money going to be spent
well we can broadly split it up into
these categories this is what the
government said actually the vast
majority of it will go on the nhs so
much more on nhs than social care in
fact social care you can see it's on the
far right-hand side there that green bit
only about three billion below three
billion because i've rounded that up a
little bit and you've got the care cap
as well so that's preventing people from
paying too much of their income and
their assets into social care so a lot
of this really is about health quite
similar to that 2002 measure from gordon
brown raising national insurance to pay
for the health system and actually when
you look at historical comparisons here
we've got the six biggest tax increases
that we've seen going all the way back
to about 1990 and just look health and
social care makes i think it is the
sixth biggest tax increase that we've
seen in that entire period so pretty
enormous uh slightly smaller than that
1997 pension tax credit remember that
raid on pension tax credits in 1997 uh
2021 corporation tax increase so that
was a bit bigger but put those two
together you're talking about one of the
biggest years for tax increases that
we've seen on record as i mentioned 2002
gordon brown 2010 vat increase 1992 vat
increase these are all enormous measures
and yet we've had this one outside of a
budget so an extra 11 billion pounds or
so just on that extra levy and when you
talk everything up and look at the
percentage of gdp here is what happens
to the tax burden so how much we're
paying the tax incidence level it goes
up a little bit look at that line just
going a little bit higher and as a
result of that 35 of gdp you're talking
about the highest level since 1969 17
you can probably just make out that was
a bit of a blip potentially around then
so really this may well go down as the
highest sustained level uh for the tax
burden ever
and also it wasn't just about taxes it
was also about the triple lock today
another manifesto pledge that was broken
previously you'll remember this the
triple lock was all about how much you
increase the state pension by it's one
of these three things either earnings
inflation or 2.5 percent well earnings
is going to come in very high indeed
we'll only find out how much next week
but 8.1 is what's expected as a result
it's not the triple lock anymore goodbye
to that and it's hello double log it's
the highest of those two things so
inflation we don't really yet know yet
or 2.5
some big changes coming in and all of it
outside of a traditional budget